most of the social that's out there
isn't working because it's selfish you
want the likes you want the money you
want to sell the thing and we don't want
that you need to put out things that
provide value and they can come in a lot
of shapes and sizes I'll tell you who
I'm really fascinated by the people who
are posting on a daily basis who have
very tiny tiny audiences and enjoy it to
no end they enjoy it because they just
want to share videos of them playing
video games or cooking or things of that
nature this becomes a very simple game
of why are you doing this if you're
doing it because you loved the thing
that you're putting out there and it's
part of the process you're gonna win